Jameis Winston quarterback Tampa Bay
Buccaneers my Thor empowered should be a
97 to 99 I think I got it wrong gone
begins Boston College right before
halftime well I like [ __ ] it like two
blockers and I Trump the ball like 50
yards down the field while dude is right
in my face I think it should be about a
95 because I know where to put ball that
so I'll receive the Cominco play speed
should be about a 95 under skin uh it
should be either 75 or like a 77 78 cuz
against Louisville I took off on them a
good long run play awareness
I got good football IQ my witness should
be releasing the 80 90 100 jump in front
by the 20
I really can't jump that high but I just
think it's something different with
jumping on grass and just jumping
regular cash it about 100 you know
nobody really seen my hands though but I
could be one of the best ideas in high
school football tackling I do a lot of
tackling this year I got do got one
forced fumble on the year you know so my
tackling should be I'm a head buster
- but my tackling should be dollar 85
don't get me wrong I be knocking them
out of there swim move you know I'll
probably be one of the most prolific
defensive ends in the country if I was
lifting more weights but I wouldn't get
the chance to play for the back cuz I
got them
I got fast hands you know I got just I
just did three moves the I leave a seat